bonjour merci d'être avec nous on dirait
que sur rt france alors la commission
d'instruction de la cjr a ouvert son
enquête sur l'infraction d' abstention
de combattre un sinistre concrètement
qu'est-il reproché à l'ancien ministre
de la santé
donc effectivement c'est cette
instruction qui est menée contre agnes
besoin la cour de justice de la
république s'interroge principalement
sur des déclarations qu'on était un peu
contradictoire entre ses déclarations
notamment après une conférence de presse
après un conseil des ministres et son
interview pour le monde après sa défaite
aux municipales donc elle va devoir
rendre des comptes sur ces deux
déclarations qui seront un peu
contradictoire pour tirer le fil de la
vérité et savoir oui ou non si
finalement elle a agi de manière
suffisamment préventif il ya eu des
décisions ou une omission de certains
faits de manière intentionnelle ou non
et rétablir le fils de la vérité donc
c'est sur ce point sur ces points précis
que va insister la cour de justice de la
république
puisqu'on rappelle qu agnès buzyn autour
des murs 2020 occuper un rôle central
dans cette crise l état puisqu'elle
était un ministre de la santé
exactement c'est vraiment un acteur
central du dispositif du gouvernement
dans la gestion de crise est ce qui nous
vaut nous interroger et qui est
particulièrement intéressant avec cette
affaire ces deux points le premier rang
c'est la question la judiciarisation de
la petite politique
traditionnellement les politiques
doivent rendre des comptes c'est normal
il faut qu'ils auront d'autres même les
ministres à rendre des combles et
principalement auprès des électeurs des
élus et lors de commissions
parlementaires au sénat ou à l'assemblée
nationale l'a cette fois ci on doit
aussi rendre des comptes face à des
juges donc plutôt à l'institution
judiciaire et c'est être capable de
trancher qu'est ce qui relève de la
responsabilité plutôt politique de ce
qui relève de la relève de la
responsabilité judiciaire donc il ya
qu'est ce qui est plus tôt en emportant
notamment avec les perquisitions qui ont
eu lieu au domicile de monsieur virant
alors qu'il n'a encore en est en
exercice de finalement avoir des
ministres qui vont plutôt gérer le
risque pénal plutôt qu'agir et de
prendre des mesures en anticipation pour
gérer la crise sinon on s'est aperçu
avec la gestion de crise et avec une
crise comme le committee of que c'est
que le plus important finalement c'est
la réactivité et l'anticipation d'être
en capacité d'agir et de s'adapter aux
changements d'information aux nouvelles
fonctions que nouvelles découvertes sur
virus est d'être en permanence le plus
habile et plus agi pour s'adapter plus
rapidement possible avec ses démarches
on peut se demander si finalement les
ministres et différentes administrations
sont pas dans une solution davantage
d'attentes pour gérer le risque
judiciaire vérifier d'abord qui ne
seront pas mis en examen il n'y aura pas
de poursuites avant d'éventuellement
prendre des décisions c'est tout le
point clé est la mise en tension entre
l'impératif de rendre des comptes et en
même temps permettre l'action et pas
paralyser l'action publique qui en
france mais déjà paralysé avec une
bureaucratie y de plus en plus
importante alors vous parlais justement
de rendre des comptes sains ya deux ans
était à l'époque ministre de la santé
elle devait donc à lui mais d'une rendre
des comptes annuels macron alors
certains je vais citer par exemple j'ai
citer que lui et alexis corbière de la
france insoumise qui ne souhaite pas
qu'elle soit le fusible nu président
comment appréciez-vous ses propos
ce que ce que ce que ce que disent et
propose un plan très intéressant c'est
que finalement l'autre enjeu et tout le
monde a en tête c'est le calendrier
électoral et finalement les élections
présidentielles de 2022 on est dans un
contexte où finalement emmanuel macron à
une cote de popularité qui est plutôt
bonne pour un président en fin
d'exercice en fin de mandat et dans le
même temps l'étude d'ipsos l'ifop paru
aujourd'hui au final que 30% des
français qui trouve tirer bénéfice de la
politique menée par le présent depuis
2010 est donc en fait le point
intéressant pour emmanuel macron c'est
le sa gestion qui sanitaires ou pour
l'instant il ya une croyance disons que
finalement les autres mais pas forcément
fait mieux avec cette instruction la
cour de justice de la république qui va
insister sur les points plus tôt les
plus défaillant sa gestion de crise
notamment sur les masses déclaration
dont il se souvient qu'ils étaient un
peu catastrophique obligatoire puis
inutile plus obligatoire on serait dans
un contexte politique et médiatique on
va revenir et demander des comptes sur
toutes les erreurs qui ont été commises
et donc finalement les français jugeront
et le climat politique sera plus
défavorable au président de république
qui ne l'est actuellement finalement la
fin de la campagne de vaccination avec
son objectif de 50 millions de doses a
plutôt été atteinte tôt soit dynamique
positive il pourrait se retrouver sur
une dynamique négative en termes de
gestion de crise et des comptes et
d'agendas médiatique sur la question
vide alors que pour l'instant par
rapport à ses autres concurrents dans la
course à sa réélection
c'est son avantage principal
actuellement est vrai que glisser merci
à vous d'avoir et on dirait que sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint du think tank
le millénaire